in Silicon Valley it's a cutthroat world
startups are just trying to stay alive
you started your own company you know
how taxing this is how do companies
manage this issue of overwork and under
sleep when they're just trying to keep
the lights on well that's really the
fundamental delusion the delusion that
by working around the clock you're going
to be more successful and all the
evidence is to the contrary that in fact
in order to be at your most productive
and your most creative and your most
resilient you need to be to have had a
good night's sleep because that's when
you operate at your best and I was
actually talking to Travis today because
he said how is a younger dabrander he
bought into that much a delusion that he
is not going to sleep and he was going
to drive himself into the ground and he
jokes he said I had failure after
failure and then I hit my thirties and I
realized that I was actually much more
effective I was a much better leader
when I was fully recharged so you have
not been shy about Donald Trump bragging
about how little sleep he gets and how
it's hurting his campaign so I'm curious
what if he becomes president what does
that mean for America so he's been
bragging for a while that he only gets
four hours sleep a night and that he
sleeps with his phone because he doesn't
want to miss out and I think ultimately
his lasting contribution to American
life is going to be as exhibit a of
sleep deprivation because he truly
portrays all the symptoms that the
American Academy of Sleep Medicine has
described as symptoms of chronic sleep
deprivation like inability to process
even basic information mood swings
outburst of anger paranoid tendencies
instability and finally he actually went
so far when he called on women who have
abortions to be punished that he had to
retract it and
doesn't retract anything maybe he
doesn't become president but nobody
thought he would get this far does it
worry you like what if he got this far
partly because of the media the media
really did not do their job because he
saw great for ratings
you know they had him on they he could
literally phone it in on any show even
the biggest Sunday morning shows which
they never allow any other kinda to do
so does this mean you're a Hillary
Clinton supporter like you we are
covering the election and we are
covering everyone and we we believe that
that's our job and but it's not our job
to pretend we don't have a very strong
position on a candidate who is
completely beyond the pay like Donald
Trump